oh [__]
it's Wednesday [__] polish your
shoes and powder your helmet we're going
deep to that a [__] beautiful
Wednesday October 3rd why cuz that's how
we roll you understand me oh yeah baby
oh yeah when you see this [__] Papa's
got for you today forget about it it's
like a [__] laxative you understand
me I got some animal cookies I got some
birthday cake
both of these [__] savages you
understand me how dare I show up with
some susquehanna during [__] sober
October you understand what I'm trying
to say to you people you gotta have a
little dignity a little [__] class
finally the dog wakes up now he's
breaking my [__] balls I need this
[__] thank that I'm a disciple of Saint
Lazzaro
[Music]
greetings - so Brock Toba I'm gonna
congratulate all my [__] brothers for
going through it I'm gonna go through it
through a different system I'm gonna
lose ten pounds by the time I get on Joe
Rogan's October 29th show to promote
mine
October 30th DeGeneres released on
Netflix you understand me that's how I'm
doing it I'm also gonna not eat sugar
and that's how you got observe something
it's like went for [__] savages you
understand me
and that's it and that's that I got the
[__] of the weed that Matt Kavanagh
smoked today I got some animal cookies
like [__] 26 percent birthday cake
it's up there with the [__] digits
thank God the urban trees over them
Ventura for [__] support and so
bumped oh boy uncle Joey here I'm good
to go it's 8:00 in the morning I'm
slinging dick giving out bubblegum I had
two spots last night at the Laugh
Factory with the [__] legend doesn't
my rarer and then I went over to the
store and saw mr. bilbary so a bunch of
[__] savages down there so you know
how we [__] do with it it's a
non-stop [__] parade you follow me as
you could type lunch so pronto business
like [__] June ever since I [__] a
dick on the [__] Netflix thing how to
reprioritize so I stopped with the
[__] edibles I incorporated strength
lifting I [__] stick to my [__]
plan and we're here we're queer the
result is what the [__] you see on stage
Boston I want to thank you for a great
weekend there Foxwoods them for treating
Lee with the utmost respect and Steve
Simone killing it
and Foxwoods it was not Wilbur Fox which
both Audrey's I love your [__]
that's what I'm trying to say to you I'm
gonna try to get Bubba joy what's with
the [__] and they're beatin let's kill
let's smoke some of that cabin ah [__]
I feel like blacking out for [__]
lunchtime [__] guy humbling and
mumbling up there poor bastard what are
you gonna do how you gonna come at me up
to 36 years you know the [__] I was
doing
36 years ago right now I was in October
hind man from the [__] cops on the
lam from the Michael's Jewish thing you
follow me so you can't judge me on that
was a different [__] Savage then but
who gives a [__] the smoke some reefer
it's supposed to start raining but I
don't give a [__] the sunshine juice in
my nutsack will keep me the [__] through
I'm already starting to see the Senate
Senate committee Jimmy the Senate
committee in front of me I see a bunch
of white people and ugly [__] white
chick trying to question me can you
imagine a [__] I [__] confusing like
the [__] do done Godfather to what do
you mean in your year you were [__]
yeah it was a button that's it that's
how it works
yeah I'm saying I was the family had a
lot of buffers that's what this is we
have a lot of buffers here
but Joey enough with the [__] air
beating let's try this [__] from
urban trees oh oh the colors I see in
here the [__] the reef like listen like
I gave some to my pet fly he finally
died that [__] I had to bury him
yesterday I don't have pet flies I think
poor flies to torture him leaves got a
pest fly that they live on his [__]
neck he's got a service fly what are you
gonna do you know I'm saying some people
need [__] service [__] help Who am
I to cry
but everything's beautiful I'm looking
on a Joey la bamba 155th Street I'm 55
I'm swinging dick and I don't give a
[__] you understand me
don't forget October 23rd the premiere
the guestbook on TBS my brother Greg
Garcia always takes care name in the
first two episodes what I do in that
first episode you're gonna die it's
never been done on TV before
you understand me it's never been done
on TV before and it's the last thing
you'd think uncle Joey we're doing a
[__] TV show so if I was you I Toby
23rd but before that are you kidding me
or what West Palm Beach next Friday and
cute and [__] Saturday look one each
year after I eat or oh yeah I kinda feel
popular SEPA Boca me see the mechanic
and my mum Bella pinga he who are Santi
see my colleague or your but I see in
Chino but pay us to get along in Chino
aiya
anyway it's a beautiful [__] day you
know I'm saying I don't know what's
going on in your world but that was
yesterday and Monday was Monday and
today's Wednesday and today's the day
you gotta worry about Friday they can
suck your dick you're just worried about
Wednesday and how you're gonna get over
today that's it that's the word getting
over today are you gonna get to your
[__] goal who's gonna stop you who's
gonna get in your way and hit me with a
left [__] store either the bus didn't
show go [__] yourself I've been there if
the bus don't show him hitchhike
hopefully you'll get [__] sexually
harassed and I'll try to [__] in
the muffler and it'll stick his finger
up his ass and give you the gay so look
you never heard that in the eighties
anyway that's a complete different party
different set of quaaludes we weren't
even eating quaaludes
we we eat in Paris [__] blues you
understand you ever hear of a Paris blue
no you're too [__] young that's why
y'all called Joe is here to explain it
to you
oh listen if you wanna see the devil you
gotta go to Ventura Boulevard and see my
boy just go behind the counter listen I
want what Joey gets I want to see the
same devil that uncle Joey gets but
remember it's so BOC Taub at least do a
[__] push-up do something a jumping
jack eat a [__] snack I don't give a
[__] what you gotta do represent you
understand my man Rogan puts it together
with those savages me you know me dawg
I'm a [__] junkie I love my marijuana
I ain't sober I [__] don't do blow I
don't do heroin I don't do [__] toxic
cops but you got something we'll take a
chance you know I'm saying let's put the
experimental cap on [__] I'm 55 I got
one foot in the grave one I'm gonna had
a pill and I don't read that at all I
don't need it
My Mind's on [__] fire already
between the Alpha brain the [__]
reefer and the egg yolks I'm ready to
stab my mother [__] do you understand me
you're too podcast up I haven't Kayden
Bonnie McFarlane tremendous next to me I
got another two weeks of [__] podcast
I'll drop in your [__] world which
whole new podcast there's no more shout
outs it's just hard to heart that's it
it's just too [__] a man and a woman
a woman whatever the [__] it is you know
I don't give a [__] I have tons of
females in there got tons of [__] men
and their cake Quigley's coming in maybe
I'll show my nutsack I'm not sure I've
been working on my nutsack lately the
skin was a little too loose you know I'm
saying I had to start doing different
exercises and now we're back a little
[__] you want to do another ball you
want to sit there like a [__] Mook on
yeah I'm cool Joey I'm at Starbucks I
don't give a [__]
take a chance roll a number go outside
maybe there's a homeless guy he's got
chlamydia on his mouth he'll give it to
you who gives a [__] you lose a tooth
but you live another day and you got a
story and I'm saying
an 83 I smoked [__] names with bus with
a pregnant black chicken all [__]
there's a kid that wanted a friend we
were one I on Facebook there damn not
sure you don't say
[Laughter]
anyway who loves you [__] more
than me nobody you know why cuz I ain't
got dick ain't got the gang that oh gods
what are you guys nothing you understand
me I didn't even [__] robbed the
first yet when you're hearing sirens and
you haven't even robbed the purse yet
that's when you know you're [__] up
I'm saying I feel like Kennedy right now
well he got shot in the head that's how
I feel like but [__] and I got to move
forward I got a 9:30 and an 11 o'clock
I gotta meet a friend to do some writing
I gotta pick my daughter up you take her
to self-defense then from there we take
a short [__] ride over and we got
swim class then from there it's [__]
pizza night then after that it's [__]
movie night you follow me you think it's
[__] tough for a pimp this is what I
gotta do I got a second chance of life
and you got a [__] jump on it like a
[__] on a Molly bow girl yeah I
loathe the moan you're laying in that
[__] casket that didn't get my might
that I being that sorry so listen it's
Wednesday
smoke some reefer look at the mirror and
tell yourself they can't stop you and if
you got a problem just spit in the
mirror you spit your face in the mirror
[__]
nej angry and hungry today but I need
the lovin yard to come true it's a tough
position to be putting angry hungry but
to love and your heart to come in and
you're gonna [__] knock them all out
today you understand me know why as i
did and i got nothing i got a seventh
grade education I got a GED I never
wanted to take my GED I only took my GED
test cos can you imagine quitting high
school and then [__] failing a GED all
I needed was a tattoo or cocoa on my
fingers I was born to lose you
understand me but no I passed the GDP I
couldn't [__] believe with his study
anyway
what why are we talking my GED I'm a
[__] up here it's Wednesday I love you
in the church episodes are up Miami West
Palm Fort Lauderdale Tampa get in the
[__] car so you [__] savages next
Friday night Saturday night and if
you're down in mile beyond [__] run
and Paul I like I don't know whatever
time I [__] wake up and I'm saying
look at me I'm gonna [__] up on the
Wednesday morning but that ain't gonna
stop me I'm gonna take a shot at e3 I'm
gonna put some [__] nice powder on my
nut sack and I'm ready to go I love you
guys remember always to the end that
didn't get my much end up being up
typically oh you for some Toni isopropyl
here higher mad flavor and then the day
I love you [__] to stay black stay
positive and tell them what a suck your
dick